split up you go over here you go over
here I'm gonna be a great dad
[Music]
what's her name
star and Stella just get up on in here
there we go yes
the thing I miss most about being a band
with my brothers is just the traveling
aspect of it
now they were with me every step of the
way we got to see amazing places in the
world together and it was a beautiful
time in our lives come back to me
knowing that people are having sex my
music is the best thing in the world I
just require a commission by way of
naming the child after me Nicholas Nick
Nicky Nicolette this should be the
exchange what inspired me to write it
this little guy obviously I would aspire
me to write it was that oh yeah this I
can't focus and this is happening so I
was at Coachella actually hey plain ice
was at a rave tent and what yeah thank
you hmm got in there and basically it
was very inspiring and every song I've
ever written in my career is jealous
really important song for me when I
broke off solo it's captured a moment in
time for me what do you think what's
your favorite song I've ever written in
your career growing up in a house full
of guys my mom's very strong woman she
had a lot of boys around all the time
I need you to us we were a handful I
imagine when we all left the nest that's
what it felt like for her they gotta be
honest trustworthy and a dog person not
a cat person today not gonna have a cat
it's fine just prefer dogs there's one
right in front of you there you go
a best piece of dating advice is be
upfront be honest even if at times it's
not always exactly what you think the
person wants to hear always the truth is
better than being dishonest or not being
upfront right right there's a little bit
of healthy competition going on between
my brother and I but I am the Godfather
of my one of my nieces and I did wear a
pinstripe suit to her dedication so I'm
fully the Godfather the best part about
it is you get to play with them and hang
out with them but then you get to have a
full night's sleep ultimate cheat meal
pizza every time or cheeseburger or
bacon cheeseburger
a burger pizza smash them together right
mark can you get out and kick it up
I do watch Game of Thrones I have many
favorite characters but every time I'd
like a character they get killed so I
have to know if I like a character not
say who I like because I just die right
away
Joe has never given me a wedgie that's a
lie
straight line straight from his mouth
he's full of [ __ ] tell him I said so do
it
rip the set down just eat it you know
lots of memorable moments from a Disney
days we used to do the Disney Channel
Games which was a good time they would
collect all of us from the different
shows and then put us together at Disney
World
really it was like summer camp and they
had the park to ourselves some nights
and lots of drama cuz we were all dating
each other and sick high school amazing
[Music]
thank you so much guys that was
beautiful thank you I'm gonna allow to
eat this [ __ ] mm-hmm
[Music]